Because all of these things can happen every cycle,
there are some interesting things that we need to consider. And those are,
can we do same cycle issue of an instruction and then immediately dispatch that
instruction in the same cycle if it doesn't need to capture any results?
Typically the answer here is no. Why? Well because while
issuing the instruction, we are putting stuff in it's reservation station, and
usually to dispatch when into test what's in the reservation station. So during
the issue cycle we are writing to the reservation station, and that reservation
station is not ready yet to be recognized as a dispatchable instruction. So,
pretty much, the reservation station is treated as empty during this cycle
while we are dispatching the instruction. And only starting in the next cycle,
that instruction becomes eligible for dispatch. But it is possible to
design the processor in a way that allows same cycle issue in dispatch. The next
thing is whether it's possible to do same cycle capture and then dispatch. So
if an instruction is sitting in a reservation station after being issued, and
it captures its last missing operand in this cycle can it also dispatch in this
cycle. Typically the answer to this question is also no. And that is because,
again, the reservation station here updates it's status from operands missing to
operands available during the cycle when it is doing the capture and next cycle,
this reservation station looks like it is something that might dispatch, but
it is, again, possible to capture operands. And consider this instruction for
dispatch. It just needs more hardware for that. And finally can we
update the RAT entry for both issue and write result in the same cycle?
What's happening here is that an instruction that is being issued might need to
update the RAT. To change the entry that belongs to it's destination operand.
Meanwhile the instruction that is broadcasting, also needs to update the RAT
that corresponds to it's destination operand. So if the instruction is being
issued and the one that is writing it's result. Have the same register that
is their destination, then this RAT entry needs to be sort of updated twice.
So can we do that? And the answer to this is typically yes,
because this is not something where the entry needs to be written once and
then written again. What we need to ensure is that the instruction that is
issuing, ends up being the one whose value is kept in the RAT.
So pretty much these two write to the same entry in the RAT.
The end result of that should be, the thing that the issuing instruction wrote.
Why? Well, because the right result instruction is trying to point others who
need to read this register, to the registers that it's going to write.
Meanwhile, the issuing instruction, which is later in the program order,
is telling the instructions that are going to issue after it,
that they need to look at it's reservation station for
the result. And because the instructions who will read the RAT are the ones
that issue even later, they need to see the latest value of the register,
which means they need to see the value that the issue instruction is producing.
And because this is a simple decision, here, you just write this one and
not this one, if both need to be written. We can do that in the same cycle.